شكرا جزيلا على هذا الخطاب هناك مزايا
وعيوب المزايا بانها شامله
والعيوب لانه ليس لدينا الان وقت من
الاسئله انا لن اسالك
اسئله ولكن اطلب من الحضور ان يتقدم سؤالا
لك الحق في السؤال لين
استمع الان الى السؤالين الرجاء رفع اليد
الميكرو لو سمحتم
سؤال قصير جدا
سيد الرئيس
هل تعتقده
بانه هناك اي حظ اي فرصه من اجل الوصول
الى سلام مستدام مع روسيا
اذا لم تتخلى روسيا عن احلامها
الاستعماريه كمقام
فيما يتعلق بالجزائر هل يمكن ان
تتوقف وتتخلى روسيا عن امبراطوريتها
سنتناول السؤال الثاني مباشره
باللغه الانجليزيه
وفقا لرؤيتك فيما يتعلق بالنظام عالمي
جديد والسلام هذا هل يشمل ذلك
اصلاح مجلس الامن الدولي من اجل الاستماع
الى الاستماع الى دول اخرى نعم سابدا
الحديث عن السؤال الثاني نعم علينا ان
نعيد صياغه النظام العالمي اعتقد اولا
بالنسبه لي هذه هذا امر ملح علينا نعيد
المزيد من التوازن ليكون اكثر شمولا في
هذا النظام العالمي وانا
نرى بان هناك
خساره للثقه في الكثير من البلدان بهذا
النظام
لماذا انا اعتقد
بان هذا العالم وغير متوازن وسيمه في
التسعينات نعم قمنا بالكثير في هذا المجال
ولكن كانت هناك مقاربه في ازدواجيه
المعايير
هناك الكثير من الاعمال في عده منظمات
فيما يتعلق بمرسومات التجاره والصحه ولكن
النتائج كانت قليله لقد عملنا بالكثير
ولكن
الكثير البلدان لم تقم بكل ما تستطيع
الان اعتقد بان هناك اثار لهذه الحرب على
تلك البلدان هو هؤلاء يقولون عندما تكون
الحرب على اراضيكم تصبح اولويه بالنسبه
لكم انتم مستعدون لصرف الاموال وتقوم بذلك
بسرعه ولكن لا تقوم بنفس الشيء بالنسبه
لنا
هناك تحديات اكبر وهناك ايضا تحديات كبرى
تمثل بالديموغرافيه والمنخ على سبيل
المثال ان الاولويه القصوى تتمثل باستعاده
التضامن واعاده بناء التضامن ونحن سنقوم
بتنظيم مؤتمر في حزيران في باريس مع
كبريات المنظمات الدوليه والدول من اجل
اصلاح المنظمات كمنظمه نقد الدوليه والبنك
الدولي من اجل التاكيد على الجانب العالمي
وهذا جزء والمسجد ام الدولي هو جزء من ذلك
ان علينا ان نقول بان عضو واحد دائم
الدولي قرر ان يقوم بالقضاء على كل القيم
المتعلقه بهذا المجلس اذا علينا ان نعيد
صياغه هذا الدولي
نعم فيما يتعلق بالتنازل عن حلم
الامبرياليه في هذا المجال
او اقدم شرحا هذه الحرب هي
نتيجه في الواقع
لا احد في اوروبا قد هضم التعبير تداعيات
الحرب البارده نحن اعتقدنا
بان هذا الامر انتهى
انهار الجدار ويمكن كل الامر ان يصبح جيدا
الوصول الى الاتحاد الاوروبي منظمه معايير
جديده ونظام جديد لا يمكن التغيير
المجتمعات تم بناءه صيغتها عبر عقود
ونحن كاروبيين تعاملنا مع نتائج ذلك ولكن
نحن قللنا ربما من شان بعض الجوانب
الوطنيه والثقافات الوطنيه
ولا سيما فيما يتعلق بهذه الازمات من اجل
التغيير
وهذا ما ذكرته قبل عده سنوات
انا دعوت الى ذلك انا تم ربما بعد انتخابي
عام 2017
ذكرت ذلك فيما يتعلق بمقاربه مع روسيا نحن
ربما لم نهضم
في
مع تداعيات الحرب البارده نعم من نفس
الوقت روسيا لم تهضم من جانبها نهايه
امبراطوريتها
وان الاسباب العميقه لهذا الاعتداء نجد
صداها بعد 1990
وهذا الولع بهذا الماضي الامبراطوريه
لننظر متوسط اجمال الناتج المحلي اكبر بلد
في العالم جغرافيا مع حدود مع الصين
المثال اذا اردت ان تعمل مستقبل بحاجه الى
احلام يكون احلام اما عبر الابتكار
هذا ما نعمله او يكون الحلم
متمثلا باوروبا جديده قائمه على اوروبا
على الثقافه
من جانب اخر تعود تستعيد عهد
الامبراطوريات والاعتداءات انا لدي شكوك
فيما يتعلق
بالقدره
نجد قصير
والسبب في ذلك
اريد هنا ان نكون واضحا لا اعتقد بتغيير
للنظام ولو لحظه واحده هناك من يتحدث عن
تغيير للنظام هناك اقول لهم اي تغيير من
سيكون الخلف من هو القائد الجديد كيف سيتم
ذلك لقد تعاملنا مع تغيرات للانظمه في
العديد من البلدان وكلها افضت الى فشل
كامل هنا لدينا نظام مع كل
نحن نريد في هذا الاطار ان نستعيد نساعد
الاوكرانيه من الاستعاده سيادتهم
وايجابي نوعا من التوازن
ومن اجل العمل في نهايه المطاف في اطار
ايجاد صياغه هم يحددونها الامل الموضوع
الان يتعلق بالصمود
للاوكرانيين ميدانيا هذا الصمون الذي من
شانه ان يجبر الروس الى العوده الى طاوله
المفاوضات ولكن نظرا لجغرافيا علينا ان
نتفاوض علينا انا اعتقد بان هذا النظام
الذي نفس الاحلام
وهذا الشعب لنفس الاحلام ولكن عن نجد
نظاما جديدا مقبولا بالنسبه لهم ودائما
بالنسبه لنا جميعا متداوله جميعا لدينا
بعض اوجه القلق الموضوع معقد نعم
علينا ان نعمل على ذلك
شكرا جزيلا السيد الرئيس هناك موضوعات
مفتوحه نتمنى ان تعود مستقبل للاجابه عن
هذه الاسئله شكرا شكرا لك السيد الرئيس
واتمنى كل التوفيق للاصدقاء الاوكرانيين